fonction de leurs croyances
budget Bachand avec la
délégation des faits.
ERIN O'TOOLE, chef du Parti
conservateur du Canada
- Je suis un chef pro-choix
et je vais toujours défendre
les droits pour les femmes
de choisir pour elles-mêmes,
point final. On va aussi
examiner les droits
de conscience pour
nos infirmières et nos médecins,
particulièrement avec l'aide
médicale à mourir.
- Est-ce qu'un professionnel
de la santé peut refuser
de donner des soins parce que ça
va à l'encontre ses croyances
religieuses ou personelles?
La réponse est oui, mais il y a
des conditions à respecter.
Et ces conditions-là varient
selon les règles qui sont
établies par les collèges des
médecins dans chaque province.
Au Québec par exemple, l'article
24 du Code de déontologie dit
que le médecin qui refuse
de prodiguer un avortement ou
l'aide médicale à mourir doit
offrir au patient de l'aider
dans la recherche d'un autre
médecin. En Ontario aussi,
le patient doit être référé.
JAGMEET SINGH chef, NPD, Canada
- Ce qui est clair, si quelqu'un
a besoin d'un tel service, et si
le médecin ne peut pas le livrer
ou le fournir, le médecin ou
le travailleur de santé doit
trouver quelqu'un qui peut
le faire.
- Mais ce n'est pas
une obligation partout au pays.
Au Manitoba par exemple,
un médecin qui refuse
de prodiguer des soins pour
ses croyances personnelles
n'a pas besoin de référer
le patient. Pour les
infirmières, au Québec,
l'objection de conscience
s'applique seulement dans le cas
de l'aide médicale à mourir.
Mais rien n'est prévu
spécifiquement concernant
les interruptions de grossesse.